11 different things happen at once i had
to get a towel from my mom my alarm
clock went off i came back press the
wrong button
all as we went live
but with that being said how are you
guys doing today
i'm the love bro um
oh no bro i don't know if it's just me
but like your audi is a little low today
audio
oh there we go yeah i think it's i think
it's good now
i was gonna say that uh angel you look a
little a little excited today man
yeah what's the uh what's got you so
excited bro
man you're looking at these two
beautiful brothers here bro
bro rami's literally like angel you look
really excited i was like
[Laughter]
i love robotic bro yo i'm excited bro
low-key just like on hell for was about
to go down next week a lot of the
viewers might not know you know
yeah so inshallah
next week
wednesday i will be touching down in
canada
i will be
seeing these two beautiful brothers in
person alhamdulillah
and we are going to get this studio
finally set up so
it's been a long time coming what is it
like a little over a year now since we
started the uh the podcast
so we got this um we got the studio
coming
and yeah
we are planning to go back to our roots
yeah you got to tell them when the first
episode drops bro
when does the first of july
first easy day to remember for everyone
all right so we're gonna hype it up
friday july 1st i was thinking of it to
be like a nice even like round number
you know
not an even number but a round number
like july 1st or july 15th or just the
first of any month and then i knew i was
like okay we only dropped podcasts on
friday so that was going to be tough so
i look in the calendar and subhanallah
july 1st is a friday
so it just works out anyway so the first
podcast will drop july 1st
for the people watching
y'all will be
uh basically insiders here
so i mean there's probably going to be a
lot of people that don't watch this
don't get to this part
so
the insider scoop is that we are going
to be recording
a
lot of videos but like i'm talking about
a lot of videos
to basically
provide content for
months because we
all of us have certain things that we're
about to embark on so we we actually
won't have the time
nor the ability to get together like
this um in the studio in person again
for at least another year
insha allah maybe even less
before that meantime we wanted to make
the most of this time together
to be able to provide this for you guys
and you know every now and then we'll
we'll throw in
the uh the random episodes while we are
separated but then just so you all know
whoever's watching uh y'all y'all get
the inside screen yeah like these
virtual live streams bro they're still
gonna get every now and then
occasionally you know if need be but
we're really trying to switch to
in-person professional studio podcast so
we're trying to bulk film and inshallah
keep you guys occupied for the next few
months
does anyone have any questions from the
viewers before we go right into
the main topic of today's video you guys
already see the title
we're going to be analyzing the
yusuf and dr jordan b peterson podcast
as the three layman inshallah
allah and while they while they ask
whatever they need to ask insha allah
none of this could really be said
without the thanks
to you guys and the support that you
gave for the sake of allah uh to help
put the studio together subhanallah when
fire told me how much you guys raised
for it i was flabbergasted
and i
i don't know it shocked me in a good way
alhamdulillah so i'm very grateful to
you guys i know the other brothers are
as well may allah make it very fruitful
and honestly this next chapter for the
three muslims and for the podcast and
for all of you guys watching as well is
going to be phenomenal inshallah i mean
why don't you tell them what i texted
you last night
the the thing i told you that's
unfathomable to me
i have to go back in my messages man oh
my god come on
you text me a lot last night bro i did i
did that
leave out the pictures bro don't tell
them about the pictures anything like
that yeah no pictures no there actually
are pictures that's the funny part
aside from the pictures bro okay
basically guys i only take too long but
i i messaged it on me last night i was
just like bro never in my life did i
imagine we would ever get this far yeah
yes
all right first question before we begin
slightly irrelevant but uh everyone
wants to t you guys can feel free to not
answer
sister salah asks are you both getting
married in canada
uh
that could be read so many different
ways
yeah that could be read so many ways how
about how about how about this
and let's let's move on
yeah
it's not it's not it's not a personal
thing it's just you know like
keeping things confidential is always
working
i want to keep it easy
it's your private life bro private life
is called the private life for a reason
now come on yeah all right let's get
that first clip in this one may love
bless you
are you even thinking about that i'm
thinking about asking that
people people think if if you're coming
all the way to canada there has to be an
incentive bro it has to be a motive
there is bro seeing these two beautiful
brothers here and then doing the studio
come on now there we go
all right without further ado let's go
right in
trying to figure out
how to be a jew and a christian and a
muslim at the same time
but become muslim that's the best way
because the beauty of islam is you get
the old testament the new testament the
last testament i mean that really is
for me
even the jews acknowledge this because
islam in many ways is a universalized
judaism it's judaism for the gentiles
very often christians marvel at how jews
miss jesus
muslims also marvel at how
christians and jews miss muhammad
although to be fair to the jews they do
acknowledge the prophet
as a providential force and and they do
acknowledge him as a
noah hiddick messenger preparing the way
for the
the coming of the messiahs and certainly
the great um father of orientalism
uh ignites goals in her he actually said
that he felt that islam was the only
religion that somebody of a
philosophical bent could actually accept
man
that was beautifully said that was
really well worded masha'allah and i
love the answer
um subhanallah
i i want to comment something that
jordan peterson kind of alluded to in
his question you know
or his statement
more so he's like i wanna i'm trying to
figure out how to be a jew and a
christian animal small at the same time
people have this really like
universalist
understanding of religion like you know
why pick one why not try and be all
um and it seems like a really you know
kind-hearted and beautiful thing like
you know you're all-encompassing and
you're all welcoming and so on and so
forth but
when you really
boil it down and kind of try something
like that you're gonna have
contradictions between judaism and
christianity christianity and islam
islam and judaism even though there's
very few between the two the
contradictions i mean between islam
judaism
you're going to find contradictions
and at the end of the day when you look
at islam just as the brother mentioned
it's a full
encompassed religion that actually
embodies parts of christianity and
judaism what it leaves out is the
the falsehood from the islamic
perspective
islam literally mentions people who
wrote the scripture with the book or
sorry they wrote the scripture with
their hand claiming it's the book of god
and so on and so forth
and changed it over time so if you were
to accept islam you would have basically
the final message and the goal should
not be as
my personal humble opinion the goal
should not be to try and
figure everything out and and bring
everything into one it should just be to
find the truth especially when you're
dealing with religion from god because
what if god doesn't want you to be a
christian jew muslim what if he doesn't
want that what if he just wants you to
be a muslim at the end of the day and
there's a way to verify that there's
ways to really argue or prove
what is true and what is false different
ways actually that
you know you can get into insha allah
but at the end of the day being all
three three and one is actually more
christian than anything if you think
about it
no i still can't get over uh
how much of a shack
looks like in his recent thumbnail bro i
can't be the only one guys head over to
his channel and check that thumbnail and
then comment right now if he looks like
a shack bro
but we're trying to keep it relevant too
rami has no idea what we're talking
about
i don't know i'm just um
what does gentiles mean
non-jew
yeah
okay
makes sense
is it kind of like how we say
not exactly because for them it's based
on ethnicity
um
and for us it's more like uh what they
believe yeah what you believe okay
yeah
i think it's beautiful though to see
that jordan peterson is actually
like delving into this yeah because at
first like
he first started with
you know and
it's it's forgivable because he didn't
have the uh information or the knowledge
about it so he was talking about the
prophet muhammad saw
that he would tell them as if you know
like this warlord and this conqueror and
all this stuff
and that's understandable you know like
if you're just reading on him from a
non-religious standpoint of you and
you're driving these conclusions from
all this stuff
but it's like he even said in that video
where he's like
i don't know
but i want to know like maybe i'm
ignorant of this and
it's beautiful to see that he's he
actually has an open mind
to it and that he's actually delving
deeper into it and the deeper he goes
dog like the more answers he's getting
and what's even more beautiful about
that is that
there's a lot of people that look up to
jordan peterson
there's a lot of people that really
value
his point of view
yeah
i agree guys mella guide jordan peterson
to islam guys make sure you write i mean
in the comments down below
but we got the next clip inshaallah if
that's all from you guys
so i want to know what it following the
islamic faith has done for your life
personally
how has it helped you put yourself
together
and also
i'm interested in again
why you found the islamic tradition
preferable let's say to the orthodox
tradition that you did you did enjoy the
rituals that were part of that at least
so let's deal with practical issues
first so
well i yeah
um
in terms of of uh of
why i chose islam i mean i'm not
completely convinced that i chose islam
i mean in some ways islam chose me as
well
so
it's you know guidance is a very strange
thing for people like i
saw an inevitability when i look back on
what happened i saw an inevitability
of of my
embracing islam
i had some very interesting experiences
that
could be term and mystical or however
you want to determine them but uh
the the tradition itself what what
struck me was one i got to keep all of
the profits
that i i believed in already and i added
in addition
uh what we consider to be the the final
prophet and just as
very often christians marvel at how jews
miss jesus
uh muslims also marvel at how
christians and jews miss muhammad
although to be fair to the jews they do
acknowledge the prophet
as a providential force and and they do
acknowledge him as a
noah hiddick messenger preparing the way
for the
the coming of the messiah so they do
recognize that he was a providential
force at least the great um
if you read george kohler's book on
jewish theology as a chapter on judaism
in islam and certainly the great
father of orientalism
uh ignites goals at her he actually said
that he felt that islam was the only
religion that somebody of a
philosophical bent could actually accept
and he wanted to to to really bring in
the gift of philosophy
into judaism that had been
that the muslims
had so richly participated in in fact
you know there's an argument that just
as judaism prepared the way
for christianity it was islam that
prepared the way for
uh for a philosophical western
christendom because if you look at the
transmission of all of that knowledge
that comes into europe it's quite
extraordinary i mean saint thomas
aquinas who's 13th century he dies in
1274 and yet he's the doctor of the
church just look at the number of times
he quotes muslims
i mean he calls average the commentator
so i think
islam
you know one of the beauties of the
religion to me is that you'll find
whatever you're looking for in it
i mean islam
you you it has a a very simple theology
that anybody can understand in sort of
the chapter that says say god is is
unique
uh god is
completely independent
god neither gives birth nor was god born
and there's nothing like god so it gives
you a very simple
theology that anybody can understand and
yet embedded in that simplicity is an
extraordinary complexity that actually
created a metaphysical tradition
that western scholars have spent their
lifetime studying people like already
called leonor or somebody it's it's like
uh maxine rodents and
uh not maxine rudison but uh
the great uh catholic uh theologian and
and a metaphysician jacques meritain
you know recognize the genius of people
like al halaj and things so within the
islamic tradition there's just an
extraordinary spectrum you can spend
your entire life and have a satisfying
life and i know people that have done
this just mastering
their ascensions of the quran and the
the actual
oral
expression of the quran through the the
rules of tajweed
you can spend your life studying
exegesis you can spend your life
studying prophetic tradition you can
spend your life studying the great
mystics of islam we have the best poets
in the world
we also have the best architecture i
mean there's nothing like the taj mahal
or the alhambra palace
and even western architecture if you
read uh stealing from the saracens she
shows how some of the finest western
architecture was basically taken from
the islamic civilization including notre
dame in in paris so you can find
incredible i know people that just
came to islam through music
i mean i know some
really professional musicians that fell
in love with arabic music which led them
into
muslim culture
people that
love
just i mean one of the most interesting
things about islam
is it is a truly universal religion in
that you can go from indonesia to
california and find all of these
different expressions of the same
central truths of islam with their own
local colorings so the west african
muslims are not like the middle eastern
muslims the middle eastern muslims are
not like the indian muslims and you have
people like uh
you know one of the great
impressionist painters
of uh of uh sweden i think he's actually
considered a national treasure
in in sweden but uh his his paintings
hang in the museum there he became
muslim
uh in in jail in uh
in um
for for actually he he shot a a matador
because he was raised but his father was
a veterinarian and he shot a matador um
because he was so horrified that they
were bringing bullfighting into france
and there was such an uproar that they
actually released him
but when he was in jail he befriended an
algerian who
used to recite quran all the time and he
ended up becoming muslim
and
and then studying in egypt and then
going back to uh
to his native land he died in spain
but extraordinary individuals so you
have people like that you have people
that
anybody can find what they're looking
for and and that is the power of the
faith i think is that it is truly a
universal faith and i think one of the
things that western people tend to do
one they don't recognize that it's a
western faith because it is it's part of
the abrahamic phase
it was in spain for centuries it's been
in eastern europe for centuries
um and even istanbul which is the great
capital of islam for centuries is half
in europe and half in in in
in the east and that's why it really
bridges these two worlds
and so there's so much i mean this is
part of the reason why i think it makes
sense for
man i gotta watch this whole thing well
like people have been talking about it
i've been putting it off but then just
seeing this little clip here is like
damn but i really want to watch this
and like two things that i want to say
um
what he was saying were like he didn't
choose islam
islam chose him
i i listen i i gotta be
i feel like a broken record saying this
but like i feel like that's
that's been my story since the beginning
like
bro like i was i was sitting in a room
on a dopamine detox feeling this pool to
read the quran and then once i started
reading it i felt these waves in my body
it's like
that can only be explained as like some
kind of mystical
mystic type experience but it's like bro
like
that was
me being chosen i didn't choose
i didn't choose
you know what i'm saying like it was
weird it was it was so weird and then on
top of the thing where he said the the
whole topic about music
and how like
some arabic music brought people
to islam because it exposed them to like
you know the muslim culture and then
they started going deep into that and
then they got into islam of course
we don't really listen to music
but before islam
before when i used to listen to music
all the time i always felt myself
like gravitating towards like arabic
style
tracks
where they have that like
that like flu or like the the drum or
something like that where it sounds like
oh it's like some kind of like desert
type track like bro i wouldn't i would
listen to this stuff and i would
literally put it in like the background
and just listen to that all the time
because it's like there was something
about it that always drew me close to it
i mean dude like even when i was a kid
for some reason like i felt most drawn
to the movie aladdin
i don't know bro like it's it's weird
like when you start looking back and you
start connecting the dots
it's it's
it's insane that's all i got to say
it's amazing how many people have such
beautiful stories about how they came to
islam they're all specific
right like your story masha allah is so
specific maliki click's story of soul
specific spin allah i'm sure
hamza yusuf is his name right yusuf
sure his story is very specific as well
subhanallah and um
i i have to ask because this has kind of
been bothering me a little bit what did
jordan peterson ask initially
was it about how he came to islam or how
what islam is done for him practically
so for the first clip the one where he
talked about become muslim it was how do
i become a jew christian and also at the
same time but the one we just reacted to
this is the second clip out of the three
we have
he asked what has islam done for you
specifically
so
i wanted to i don't feel like enough
people talk about the practicality of
islam so i just want to quickly jump
into it a little bit to the best of my
ability you know i'm not a shaykh no
scholar but
islamically speaking
it's the most
like practicality is is i don't want to
say half the religion right but it's
if you look at how we live it's
it's everything islam encompasses
everything practically speaking right
even things like if you don't know go to
those who know is something that allah
tells us in the quran meaning that you
go to those of knowledge go to the
doctors go to specialists go to
professionals go to the scholars and ask
whatever you need to know
but if you look deeper and deeper and
deeper
everything a muslim does they're
supposed to ask you know basically
am i permitted to do this is this halal
is this permissible you know if you want
to engage in a new business well you
have to look at this business is
something that allah allows islamically
so when you look at that practicality
some people they see like a chain and
handcuffs and like a jail cell like you
can't do anything but if you look at the
number of things that are haram versus
the number of things that are halal you
find that
there's actually significantly more
things you're allowed to do than not
allowed to do the problem is we live in
a society that's so incumbent on getting
you to indulge in you know promiscuity
and interest and all these things are
haram
because you can see the damages of them
so islam is the most practical religion
in the world because we have an entire
science islamic science dedicated to
the scholars determining what we're
allowed to do what we're encouraged to
do what we shouldn't do what we have to
do and what is
discouraged in islam and so it's the
most practical thing
bro that blows my mind but
not only
are there
you know basically more things that are
held and more things that haram why
don't you tell them how many more ways
there are to get good deeds versus how
little ways there are to get sins
yes
so with these with this practical side
of islam
you know you when you really break it
down into a chart you have kind of i
think five categories you have what's
obligatory things you need to do as a
muslim
you have encouraged things that are
recommended you have halal meaning it's
permissible you're allowed to do it you
have discouraged meaning that you
probably shouldn't do it it or it's
disliked and you have haram which is
prohibited you're not allowed to do it
if you look at
the first two categories obligatory and
recommended if you do them
you get a good deed right you get a good
deed so that's two down you get good
deeds if you don't do something
obligatory you're sinful right
if you don't do something recommended
nothing happens
it's just if you want to do it you'll
get a good deed
right
if you if you look at something that's
disliked on the opposite end people
would think if i do something that's
dislike i'll get a sin that's not true
it's allah is so merciful god is so
merciful if you do something disliked
you're not sinful but if you avoid doing
it
if you say you know it's disliked it's
disliked i'm going to stay away you get
a good deed so now that's three ways to
get a good deed if you look at a sin
right you look at a sin
if you do this in your sinful right
that's why it says it if you avoid doing
it like what's disliked right if you
avoid doing it you got a good deed so
you have four ways to get good deeds and
only two ways to get a sin and with
those two ways to get us in
if you avoid doing it
you get good deeds so on top of this
practicality with things that
you know we we know how to live life
basically perfectly
with guidance from god as a muslim
on top of that
god makes it so much easier for us to
kind of
get the these rewards in bulk
more rewards than sins and that's just a
beautiful mercy of god
subhanallah bro and i don't know how
authentic this is but i read somewhere
that if you do a good deed or if you
think you have the near you want to do a
good deed you get one hustle one reward
and if you actually do it you get ten
and then if you think about doing a sin
you get no
sin
but if you do it you get one yeah tell
me how merciful that is bro that's like
a ten to one ratio yes
and on top of that allah says in the
quran if someone you know commits sins
and then repents sincerely allah may
actually turn their bad deeds into good
deeds because allah as he says in the
quran allah intends for them is allah
intends for them basically goodness
allah doesn't want to misguide someone
allah doesn't want to punish necessarily
allah doesn't you know will for us to
have a horrible life and a horrible
afterlife allah wills for us good allah
wills will's first guidance and
the one thing that if you ask allah for
he will always give it to you is
guidance
on the straight path
so
you see how obviously not just practical
islam is but how comforting spiritually
islam is and that's something else if
you want to put that in the realm of
something that's practical
because
it makes you you know more content it
makes you happier which would make you
more capable in your life more confident
in your life more whatever in your life
and me personally i find that a lot to
be honest it's i don't know about you
guys sam is made more more confident as
a person because i'm not confident that
i'm great i'm amazing i'm so
knowledgeable i'm so i'm confident that
what i have is truth from allah and i'm
blessed i'm more so grateful actually i
think that's the term grateful and
there's the last thing i'm going to say
because i know i've been talking a lot
you know how i think i mentioned this
before but you guys know how you know
sometimes someone looks at you they're
like oh you can't do that and you get
mad and then you really want to do it
right that's a big motivator for you
that anger is a motivator
apparently
the the best
motivator
when you're talking about feelings and
emotions is actually gratitude
gratitude is what motivates someone to
work the most and i've witnessed it you
know at the job i'm working on that i'm
very grateful to allah and to my to the
brothers um that i work with
it makes me want to work more so when a
person is grateful to allah it actually
makes them want to work more and that's
why you see you know this beautiful
character in a lot of the muslims out
there i'm not talking about myself
obviously but you know you look at the
muslims out there you see they have such
this beautiful character this beautiful
aura to them there's confidence to them
and
you know it's probably not from them
it's probably just from them being
grateful that they have islam and that
they're guided from allah
no no i agree bro couldn't say better
we got one uh comment from a member
sister again yep also if you do ascend
the angels will depend it's not written
straight away you have a time frame to
ask for forgiveness and repent survival
yeah and even if you miss that time you
can still repent afterwards
all right last clip and then we'll wrap
it up inshaallah
religious people
christians jews and
islamic alike to focus on
their commonalities in the face of the
things that are disintegrating our
cultures
we could start by trying to make some
peace between us if we're going to
consort ourselves reasonably as
religious individuals
right and i commend you for trying to
to do some bridge building because
i you know arguably
um
there there's been so much negativity
around this faith and around its
adherence
that there's an almost instantaneous
um association with the most negative
aspects of humanity with the religion
and and it's it's quite tragic and so
just as an exercise a kind of
bracketing for a second and try to try
to think about things
a mentor of mine and a friend of mine dr
thomas cleary wrote a book called zen
koans he also translated the quran he's
one of the brilliant translators of the
of of our lifetime
but he wrote a book called zen koans and
in the introduction of that book he
actually says
that the purpose of a koan is to snap
people out of of of slack
but he says in there but you don't need
a co-on to do that just ask an educated
western person what they think about
islam
and they'll start expressing all of
these prejudices and if you ask them
have you ever read the quran no do you
know anything about the prophet muhammad
no
other than maybe something they read in
a a newspaper article or in time or
newsweek or the atlantic monthly
something yeah well it's not it's not an
easy thing to try to get a toehold in a
different tradition especially it's not
that i don't even have a toehold in your
own
yeah it's not that hard especially for
an educated person you're obviously a
highly educated person it's not that
hard islam one of the things given said
is that islam spread because it's it was
a very easy religion to understand so
this idea that i can't understand it i
can't
i'm having a hard time it's not that
hard to understand
i mean islam is actually a very
straightforward
okay then give me a give me a
five minute
summary of the core beliefs
i i don't want to put you on the spot
i'm it's not a question no no no no
it's not that's not hard at all
so so lay it out that would be very so
so we have a famous hadith in which
uh
we're we're told that the
angel gabriel came in the form of a man
and asked the prophet
tell me about faith
and and the prophet muhammad said faith
is to believe that there's only one god
and that muhammad which includes all the
previous messengers is a messenger of
god
to believe in angels to believe in the
books that god has revealed
to believe in the last day the day of
judgment and to believe in the
measuring out of good and evil that good
and evil is part of life and then he's
oh and he said islam is that you
make the testimony of faith that you
pray five times a day that you fast
ramadan that you pay zakat
uh the 2.5 of your standing wealth at
the end not your income tax but your
standing wealth at the end of the year
that's a whole year 2.140 is given to
poor people there's eight categories
that are given in the quran
and that you if you're able to you make
a pilgrimage once in your lifetime to
mecca and then he said tell me about
ichsan
which is the third dimension of islam
and he said and this is the dimension of
virtuous being by being a person of
erity of excellence in the world and he
said
is to worship god as if you see god
and if you and if you don't see him at
least you know that he sees you so you
have an awareness
of that that that you're that there is a
divine presence
and you should be in a state of
awareness in your behavior i mean one of
the things about
you know if you're driving and
everybody's speeding and then somebody
sees a cop they all suddenly slow down
you know i have a friend once who
just zoomed past the cop when everybody
slowed down and he pulled him over and
he said why didn't you slow down he said
i felt like a hypocrite
so the guy
he let him go
but you know that's people when they're
in the presence of authority they tend
to behave well
unless they're an utter rebel i mean
there are those people
i'm trying to figure out
how to be a jew and a christian and a
muslim at the same time
but become muslim that's the best way
because the beauty of islam is you get
the old testament the new testament the
last testament i mean that really is for
me
even the jews acknowledge this because
islam in many ways is a universalized
judaism it's judaism for the gentiles
we have the mikvah you know they do
hustle we have a little soul i mean you
know which is the ritual
uh the the baptism a total immersion in
water ritually to to purify yourself
which is done at least once a week
man subhanallah i never thought of that
bro
as like a link to baptism i know it's
comparing apples to oranges bro but
in a way of purifying
yourself yeah yeah 100
i uh
i think you did a really good job of
summarizing islam because we do have a
hadith that summarizes it it's very
beautiful uh one more time i want to
emphasize i feel like
i mean even from a
kind of salesman perspective and we're
not salesmen we're not trying to sell
anything right we're not actually
muslims if you look at it the way the
quran talks about selling
is when allah he mentions that people
sold their afterlife for a small benefit
in this world like pennies and they sold
eternity and bliss
when they you know lie about scripture
for a prophet like you make up a verse
saying you know give rami 20 bucks every
time he says a few words to you know
what i mean like it's like okay 20 bucks
i might be a millionaire or whatever but
then i lose everything after life right
that's what allah talks about selling
but when you look at
trying to convince people
you have to show them if they don't
understand already the problems that
they have and then give them a solution
to their problems right people love that
everyone loves that people don't like
problems people love solutions that's
why every product that does well exists
because it solves some kind of problem
so islam is not a product right islam is
the truth from god but still we are
human beings so we're going to have that
aspect of needing that solution so when
you show people how honestly miserable
they are
everyone without islam at some point in
their life is going is going to realize
how absolutely miserable they are
whether it's
when they go and they see a guy in a
white lab coat telling him that he's
going to die soon
or they lose a girlfriend or they lose a
boyfriend or they you know
their business fails they're going to
find at some point in their life they
are absolutely miserable and they cannot
pinpoint why islam offers that solution
100 but what islam also offers and
something that's overlooked a lot is
this beautiful
way physically literally to live your
life
i'm not just talking about connecting
god that's that's one of the most
beautiful things but i'm not talking
about it because it's highlighted a lot
what i want to focus on is what jaffar
what uh what jafar ibn uh uh event olive
said
he said when the najashi
i think the king of abyssinia
asked him what is islam what are you
talking about what are you bringing
he didn't you know just mention he
didn't just mention worshiping god and
all that he gave practical answers he
said we were a people that were
basically filthy
we used to take advantage of the poor
right we used to basically eat dead
flesh we used to gamble we used to
worship idols we used to do all these
abominations basically
we were in basically a filthy state and
islam came and it wiped all of that away
it cleansed us of that it taught us
basically be good to the poor take care
of the orphans so on and so forth all
these beautiful practical things
and
that's a huge part of islam
i don't have anything to say
my bad bro is changing the
commenting to subscribers
oh no worries oh it's on members only
was on members only yeah you know how we
do at the end of the thing yeah we got a
new member shout out to gucci gang who
writes to add to the mercy if you intend
on doing a sin and then stop yourself
you get a good deed
as well yes subhanallah
we shouldn't invite jordan peterson on
the podcast
inshallah bro i think i think when we
get some in-person podcast through
inshallah we'll make it happen inshallah
that would be sigma imagine having
jordan peterson in person man
should we should we give him a little
little scrap bro a little snippet of who
our first in-person guest is going to be
i don't know what do you think
i think we should leave it a surprise
okay that should be a surprise cool
we'll keep that a surprise and inshallah
okay but
i know 126 viewers brought me like
should we have
300 300 bro if we don't have 300 likes
that's it bro all right it's my love
first question pogboy69 what do you do
when a close friend deeply offends you
tell them
yeah
you have to express yourself
honesty is the best policy but it's how
you express yourself
exactly
very important
yeah just something simple
like let's say they say something that's
supposed to be a joke or whatever you
say listen i understand you're joking i
understand don't mean it but that
actually offends me so let's not talk
about that don't make jokes like that
i'd appreciate that that's it doesn't
have to be you know you flipping off the
rails and cussing at him or something
crazy like that
yeah
there's no reason to be tyrannical
or domineering or anything like that
yeah
yeah and if it doesn't stop
don't be friends with them sure yeah
another question we got it's not in the
youtube comments but we get this dm a
little more frequently now
recently
but uh
basically says uh
people are asking if if we know a good
spanish translation to the quran and has
already answered that but i know why
don't you answer it again for anyone
that's watching now and they're curious
oh well i don't know per se but my best
assumption would be
the clear quran in spanish
hmm
a few years ago is understanding your
mortality once you understand how close
we are to death i've i found i saw islam
in a much more deeper way subhanallah
okay next question yes right so what
books do you recommend
you know actually
i've seen this one video i didn't see it
but i saw the thumbnail of muhammad
yeah it was it was a question like oh
what book should i read
and he's like this isn't a question that
you should ask
and i i kind of explain like
my or whole understanding behind this
before even watching the video because
i'm ignorant to what he said probably
says some gems
but from what i understand is that when
you ask like oh what book recommendation
do you have
um you're probably not gonna read those
books
you know it's like
it's like if you're if you're looking
for the answers
you will seek
more versus just asking and expecting
someone to just
give you the answer to you
right like let's say you're trying to be
um let's say you're trying to have a
successful youtube channel
and then you go you just go to a
successful youtuber and you're like
hey like
what do you recommend to make my youtube
channel as successful as possible so
yeah you'll get some good information
but
you probably would have got the same if
not more information if you would have
just done the research yourself
yeah yeah that's true that's true and
you'd probably understand it on a deeper
level as well because you're looking
into it yourself because when you tie
when you tie kind of practicality with
concepts and stuff when you tie
different concepts that you're learning
yourself and venturing off together it
does bring a deeper understanding to it
what i would say
is
just kind of from my own perspective
that's the wrong question
because it's not specific enough right
what question should i write read what
are you trying to learn if you're trying
to learn about him okay there are books
you can read that one of the one of the
the greatest books if you want to read
syrah there are many books on surah
but this is the thing i don't recommend
people just read books especially if
you're like like us you're just laymen
don't just read books because there's a
lot of things in there especially when
it's translated you're going to read
you're not really going to understand
conceptually learn islam especially in
the science of stem under a teacher
someone who's learned it and they might
actually this is the thing teachers
learned knowledgeable teachers and
sometimes scholars as well actually most
of the time scholars will teach you
based off a book
they'll teach you based off a book from
another teacher or from one of the uh
greater scholars in the past like um
imam shafi rahm allah for example or
imam and now we are allah they will
teach teachers who know will teach based
off these books so for you to go read it
yourself just be careful
yeah and we're not saying that
we're not trying to put you down
or make you feel some type of way for
asking that question
but instead of asking this question
why not ask yourself like okay
why
or what what am i actually you know like
romney said what am i actually trying to
get into what books or what concepts
what ideas am i trying to get into
and then why like why like what's my
intention behind this
and then from there like
once you have those answers and you have
your knee straight
then find better ways instead of just
asking for recommendations
yo i know bro i got a question for you
how do you get a deeper voice
well
for the most part
if you want like a super deep voice
it's genetic
but
if you want to bring your voice to this
natural depth
then you just gotta learn to
be
i guess truth out and then the most
simplest sense i might even make a
remake of the video that i made a long
time ago and just uh like really sim
like dumb it down
because it's like people don't realize
when they are tense
when they're anxious
and all this stuff it creates
um
the the word for is an erotic holding
pattern but to make it simple
is imagine you have um
i'm trying to figure out like that
nowadays
imagine imagine this but imagine you got
a cup of water
right you got this cup of water if you
go to port
if the cup is perfect if there's no
cracks in it there's no bents no nothing
it'll pour out perfectly
but if you've got like all these cracks
in it you've got these like weird like
divots bends and you've got like stuff
congealed inside of there when you're
going to pour the water out it might
come out to this crack over here it
might be stuck on this ledge right here
and um you're not really going to get
that good water flow and then you might
get some water and then some might come
out like
too much at once and not enough like
little drips so the whole point i'm
trying to make is that if you can relax
you essentially let your voice
be at its natural depth which is
more deeper than what what it is right
now usually when you wake up in the
morning you are most relaxed and your
voice when you wake up in the morning
that's where your voice should actually
be at
so if you wake up and your voice is
pretty deep well then
say alhamdulillah and start learning how
to be chilled out and you will notice
your voice get deeper
on the law bro great answer
chainsaw man writing shout out to my guy
fired my bengali bro alhamdulillah shout
out to me free palestine
i mean
i'm in europe
it's fighting bengali bro it's crazy
that
after 24 years of life
50k subs in
we got someone who knows my ethnicity
clearly better than me subhanallah
i'm just playing bro salman writes i'm
hindu but i keep coming to your channel
big
that's what it is bro
i came to know about islam from angel on
whose journey has been very beautiful
masha'allah
maliki was good bro
keep up the good work on her
thank you amanda's made so much progress
masha'allah
jesus writes your honor philosophical
today man subhanallah
mashallah
okay last question today i know this is
not a live q a but we don't want to take
it too long so inshallah brother
muhammad writes how is weed really haram
shrooms what if it brings you closer to
allah don't have the same effects of
alcohol and our brain has receptors for
thc and for
drones and the kettlebells let me let me
go into this before romney jumps in
because i feel rami has something to say
yeah
so the receptors that we have in our
brain are called
not
and then ananda mine or something like
that i'm gonna get back to that i'm
gonna get back there's a certain word
for it but it's a certain receptor that
we have
that receives the
cannabinoid right the cannabinoid
now this doesn't mean that it needs to
be exogenous
which means it's
external doesn't mean you have to smoke
doesn't mean you have to take drugs in
order for you to anand the mind that's
what it's called anandaman it doesn't
mean you need to get this from an
external source it means
that your body can actually produce this
naturally
and when it produces it naturally it
will have the same effect
as if
you smoked weed as if
you took a psychedelic
all right so your question like oh why
is it haram it's haram because you can
you can release it naturally as it
should be and then it's even more so
haram because when you do these things
it's actually
[Music]
what's known as fake
spirituality fake progress
because if you actually talk to a lot of
spiritual people even people outside of
islam people actually part taking these
things on
even the gurus in
hinduism like
they completely
tell people to not take these things why
because when you take these things it's
they call it like unearned
wisdom unearned knowledge unearned
experience and for the most part you do
these things and
what you experience is too much for you
to handle
it's too much for you to handle so what
you end up getting is maybe like one
percent of what you experience and that
one percent you won't process it and
fully comprehend and understand it until
maybe like a year or two years later
i don't know this well i'm not gonna you
know go into details but i do know this
i do and a lot of this is associated
with a lot of trauma and other stuff
that comes with the honor wisdom that
you weren't ready for sometimes too bro
yeah and subhanallah what you were
talking about is is the exogenous
cannabinoids like found in thc cbd bro
we really don't need these you said we
have receptors in our body yeah but just
like brother angel said
the natural endorphins that our body
produces when we work out when we have
intimacy when we feel high naturally
that's what those receptors are for bro
now you can put other stuff in those
receptors but should you well that's not
what no bro
you are correct in that but what he's
referring to is the
like cannabinoid receptor
yeah it's it's for ananda mine and it's
a it's a specific thing it's not an
endorphin at least from what i know it's
not endorphin it's a specific thing
that's released
in um certain states
you know when you're in like a very
like
peaceful like blissed out state your
body will release anandaman
and that's like the same feeling as if
you were you know
smoking or doing a psychedelic and the
last thing i want to say is that
there's this analogy which says uh
when you have to ask
god something you have to ask allah
something
you
there's this phone and you pick up this
phone
and allah gives you an answer and then
you put the phone down because it's like
you can only handle that answer you
can't handle anything else you got your
answer you hang up the phone that's it
there's no need to stay on the phone
because you already got your answer
when you take
a psychedelic so when you smoke weed
what ends up happening is like you pick
up this phone
you get the answer you were looking for
but you can't put the phone down the
phone is stuck
so now you're receiving way more than
you can handle way more than you asked
for and this phone won't go down until
the trip is over and once the trip is
over you've already been
over stimulated overwhelmed
and that's why i said you only really
take like maybe one percent of it so
it's like
why if in a year if it if you did let's
say you took psychedelics you did it
once
and then you waited a year you only got
one percent of that right versus if you
would have just
prayed more
meditating more self-reflected more
within that same year spent you probably
would have made 10 times the progress
so instead of one percent you probably
would have been like ten percent maybe
fifteen percent
you see what i'm saying
i agree bro and just like brother ali
said y'all should watch our gin series
if you haven't we fully dissected
psychedelics weed all that stuff but
also the the advice that i'm gonna give
is the advice that allah the wisdom that
allah the hikmah and knowledge that
allah said in the quran
when allah clearly writes that yes there
is benefit
in things like alcohol like bro no one's
denying this allah literally writes that
although there is some benefit there is
little benefit in these things these
intoxicants
the harms far outweigh the benefits
and that's why these are haram these are
these are prohibited
we're not denying what you're saying
that yes you know you can get these you
know spiritual breakthroughs and you can
have these ego debts and we're not
denying any of that
but
is it worth it bro is it better than
doing it yourself naturally
i don't think so
yeah yeah 100
now i want to take a a different
approach kind of just
because you guys honestly
like i'm trying to encapsulate all the
information i got receptors and
i couldn't subhanallah me uh may allah
bless you guys immensely so i'm not even
gonna go down that road i'm gonna get
lost down there so all i'm gonna talk
about is is what i know uh
which is uh islamically speaking
when you say that it's not an intoxicant
and toxic it doesn't just mean alcohol
it doesn't just mean something you drink
that is uh you know basically like uh
alcohol or beer or anything like that an
intoxicant is anything that intoxicates
your mind or puts some kind of burden on
your ability to think your perception
all that basic stuff literally basic
stuff uh so if you're tripping like
crazy because of something then yeah
it's an intoxicant so scholars do
something called chaos which is
analogical deduction on that term
intoxicant and they find that anything
that intoxicates your puts you in a
intoxication whether it be weed or
shrooms or whatever it is
counts as intoxication counts as an
intoxicant and means it's haram the same
way alcohol is haram so you need to
avoid it now you need to ask yourself a
question
are you trying to get into doing drugs
because it's rational for you or are you
trying to rationalize it because it's
something that you do
you have to be very careful with asking
yourself am i doing what allah allows me
or am i trying to make allowed things
that allah made wrong because it seems
like and i'm just taking a wild guess
here you're someone who has taken drugs
or wants to take drugs you know someone
who has and you're trying to rationalize
why it makes sense to but let me use the
same argument back to you we have a
certain guy specifically have a certain
part of their body in a certain
haram to penetrate area that if they do
you know it feels good
does that mean that that's the point
that you should penetrate there that you
should get that feeling just because you
have that kind of receptor there just
because you have that kind of no it's
actually very specifically clearly haram
in the quran that allah specif
specifically addresses it and says this
is haram
so
again you know you can't come and use
your own you know wisdom and rationality
to try and come to a conclusion because
you and this actually ties in perfectly
with what i was saying before you can
never figure it out practically speaking
you and me take every human in the world
all together one they're not gonna agree
and two even with all their best answers
together they're still gonna fall short
so all we can do is submit to allah the
all knowledgeable to all wise and listen
to him and obey the messenger who
reveals the revelation from allah clear
cut easy
makes it easy for you you just have to
listen
there we go bro
let me let me let me see
i gotta finish it off bro finish it off
bro then
yeah so
you just broke my chain
[Laughter]
should i backtrack
now go ahead and read it bro
so no that is this question bro i was
just gonna say like you had three
alternative viewpoints but at the end of
the day
most people that are doing things that
they shouldn't be doing they already
know deep down what they're doing is
something that they shouldn't be doing
bro
you could lie to you you know you could
lie to your your friends you could lie
to us but you can't really lie to
yourself and you can't rely on allah bro
so at the end of the day you know what's
what
take a take a look take a reflection at
your name if that's really your name bro
you have the name of you know the final
prophet the messenger of allah
who died for this ummah bro who who who
bled for this ummah and sacrificed and
persevered through so much bro
and at the end of the day bro these
things that you're doing that bring you
temporary joys and pleasures bro it's
not worth it at the end of the day
yeah and
remember like
allah gave us
limited
understanding
limited ability to understand
why did he give us this limited ability
to understand
so that we could reflect and we could
comprehend his signs
and his mercy and his love
and all of this and his wrath as well
but if he would have given us
the same
understanding
as his understanding
oh bro
that would ruin everything
that would ruin everything
then we would think of ourselves as god
stuck for allah there are people
are people who think this way
yeah i don't even think we're i
literally think we're not even made to
be able to comprehend
like a percent of what allah knows like
imagine that man yeah
this is crazy found a lot and the just
kind of to give perspective to people
imagine a pie chart right a pie chart
with three categories
the smallest category it's really slim
are things that you know you know for
example you know there are cookies you
know there's a formula for cookies and
you know the formula for cookies and you
know that you know it imagine you didn't
know the recipe for cookies you know
that you don't know it
there's imagine you even know cookies
existed you didn't know they exist you
don't know that you don't even know
because it's not it's not a thing to
begin with and you have no idea even has
a recipe because you don't know it
exists that's like 99 of this pie chart
things you don't know exist
and so you don't even know that you
don't know them
and to sit here with your
point zero zero one percent knowledge of
everything that exists and to act you
know as if you can be like well you know
we have receptors in our brain therefore
we should be able to do it
i mean no hatred to you my man i'm in
the same boat as you i just i'm willing
to recognize it you know i'm stupid when
it comes to this this stuff i can't
decide myself and neither can you
yeah what's that bro
all right i think we should add i do i
do want to touch on the last point that
the our hindu brother chainsaw man who's
writing
he wrote that i've watched videos about
turkish mosques those are damn beautiful
i want to visit them
so visit them bro insha allah you know
but he also writes i want to follow
religion i want discipline purpose in
life
life without religion is pointless life
without religion is getting nihilistic
i'm getting lost come to islam let's
send him the link and bring him to to
accept his shahada right now inshallah
yes
if you're still there bro we invite you
on if you want to come just chop it up
real quick
or if you don't want to bro dm me on
instagram one word fide fit
f-a-i-y-a-d-f-i-t
and i will respond inshallah you can get
on a call with us privately if you don't
want to come on but if you do want to
come on now bro you can come in audio
only
um no pressure though so no no like
agenda or anything but if you want to
ask us anything if you want to talk
we're here for a little bit before
jummah
which is our friday prayer
but aside from that bro i think we'll
wrap it up
we'll wait about like another minute if
he wants to come through
vladimir writes i listen to music and
get motivation to work out from
zize or zees
zees i remember zees bro am i sinful am
i sinful
i don't know
allah
i can't really say anything on this man
muhammad as he can
who uh talked about weed
he writes uh how about cbd oil bro i
would consult a scholar
and ask
cb cbd or i mean again consult a
scholarship but there's no
psychoactive compounds in c video so
it's mostly uh medicinal
which at that point like
i personally don't see anything wrong
with it but again consult of shape
because you we're not we're not you know
we're not qualified to give [ __ ]
money which is even longer
yeah
and even then like even weed in and of
itself like
haram is
case for case type thing so if someone's
like going through
let's say a debilitating like cancer or
something like that where um
a certain strand of
cannabis
would actually
aid them in their healing and all that
stuff like if it's deemed worthy by
shaking he deduces everything like it
would actually be permissible for this
person it's like
in the quran it says um don't eat pork
right
but if you were in a situation where you
were about to die
then it is
it would be
haram for you not to eat the pork
so it's like of course it's a
case-by-case
uh situation and you have to consult
somewhat of knowledge that's what it is
wrong that's what it is
omar asks or writes all forms of drugs
or haram soft or hard drugs not bro like
tylenol it's from what i know it's not
haram
prescription medications that you need
bro
it's there's there's specific nuances in
what classifies something as an
intoxicant as psychoactive that makes a
haram
there's a whole
you know islamic science dedicated to
understanding
bro so
i don't think we could just write all
drugs
also where will your in-person podcast
be held it will be held at secret
location number 69 this is something we
can't actually you know tell you guys
but
you guys will know where it is inshallah
at least you'll see the inside of it so
think of it like that chainsaw man
responded he writes guys it's night here
thanks for responding to my comment i
will read the english version of quran
first rami what do you recommend to him
for a good translation of the quran for
an english translation i recommend the
clear quran translated by dr sheikh
mustafa
we're doing the least that we could do
and at the end of the day we just want
to leave you with something to just
reflect on and just think about
and to just
pray to allah praise the khara do some
research and inshallah make the rest of
your life the best of your life don't
make the same mistakes that a lot of
brothers did
yo so i have a question
that i wanted to run by you guys
but i guess i'll run on live too just in
case anyone on the stream lives
in canada and is in the area but do any
of you own like a manual transmission
car
no no do you do you know anyone that
owns a manual transmission car
no dude i'm trying to learn man
i've i've driven it before it's pretty
fun
yeah no i know how to drive like manual
like on a motorcycle which
you you understand like the whole gear
shifting and
throttle control and all this stuff so
like i guess that'll transfer over in
terms of learning on the car but
like i actually need to learn because
if i'm driving overseas bro like i know
most of the cars overseas or
manual transmission
yeah there are people you can pay that
offer lessons in their own car yeah
yeah
you can find that but between me and you
it'll probably be hella pricey in canada
so if you go to any other like country
where it's a little more offshore
cheaper
i might get the same experience for like
a fraction of the price
or if there's a
brother
that may live in the area
inshallah if you're watching this
can uh
can direct me in the right direction
inshallah
oh we actually got a
one last uh super chat
fomo tv right so spilling water and salt
for protection shirk
i'm pretty sure i think that's baseless
that i don't know if it's classified but
i think it's baseless
that you spill water and salt i don't
i've only seen this in like movies and
all that stuff i don't know if there's
any islamic basis for vascular scholars
yeah if there is any authentic see the
thing with with most things we do in in
islam
everything is halal by default unless
it's explicitly proven haram however
things that are ibadah acts of worship
things like you know for protection
these things these should be explicitly
from quran and sunnah so if this is
baseless like what rami is saying it's
just from tv or whims and desires or or
culture or anything like that it's it's
baseless at the end of the day we we
don't know if it's shirk
but does it eventually lead to kofir is
it a bidder you know you got to ask
yourself these questions but is it shirk
i don't know but that's assuming it's
not from the religion because i've never
heard of this to be from sun or anything
like that
yeah so i got a i got a question for you
fire we should end it off with this
question
when you're gonna grow your beard out
um
give me insha allah
august 2022
really
bro inshaallah how long you gonna grow
it
how long am i gonna grow up probably as
long as i can bro inshallah
yeah bro why not
only starting rights i have manual it's
very easy you can learn in a few days if
you can ride a motorcycle
my guy wrote dang haha he put him on the
spot bro get ready for that when we get
in person podcast we're about to put
each other on the spot like every two
seconds rami's not even ready for that
bro
then again the vibe between me and her
are going to be different because this
is the first time i'm meeting ango
as a muslim this is this is new
territory for me so
you know inshallah
again for the first time bro yeah bro
and you're meeting romney for the first
time though
you got me blushing
all right guys if you made it this far
smash that like button stay tuned for
july 1st friday july 1st insha allah in
person studio podcast first episode
drops and you'll get weekly episodes in
um